a former CIA officer suspected of
possibly giving secrets to China is
charged this morning with retaining
classified information 53 year-old Jerry
Chongqing Lee made an initial federal
court appearance yesterday in New York
Lee a resident of Hong Kong is a
naturalized US citizen and Army veteran
he is accused of unlawfully having
notebooks containing national defense
information including names of covert
CIA assets Jeff Piquet's is in
Washington with how the case may be a
major part of a US intelligence setback
good Jeff good morning good morning
investigators moved in on Monday night
to arrest Lee at New York's JFK Airport
after he flew in from Hong Kong
according to court papers Lee work for
the CIA as an overseas case officer from
1994 to 2007 in August of 2012 he moved
his family from Hong Kong to Virginia
during that move investigators searched
two of his hotel rooms where they found
two small books containing handwritten
classified information including phone
numbers of assets and covert CIA
employees sources tell CBS News Lee is
suspected of possibly being behind a
leak of information to the Chinese last
May the New York Times reported that
more than a dozen US intelligence
contacts had been killed or imprisoned
in China from 2010 to 2012 it's still
not clear why it took authorities six
years to bring charges against Lee he
was interviewed by the FBI five times in
2013 but later left the country without
being charged if convicted he faces up
to 10 years behind bars
Gael thank you very much Jeff